Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Hello everyone, the
dialectical materialism of
Marxist-Leninist philosophy has two basic principles: the
principle of universal interconnectedness and the
principle of development. In
this video, I will share with you the principle
of universal interconnectedness first. I
guarantee that after watching the whole video, you will
understand this issue perfectly.
The video will cover the concept, nature, and
significance of the principle of universal interconnectedness,
and then I will give specific practical examples
to help you understand it easily.
If you find this video helpful,
please give me a like, subscribe to the
channel, and leave a comment in the comments section. Okay, let's get started!
First, let's
understand what interconnectedness and universal interconnectedness are.
The concept of
interconnectedness refers to the determination,
interaction, and transformation between
things and phenomena, or between the aspects and
elements of each thing and phenomenon
in the world. The concept of
universal interconnectedness refers to...  The universality
of relationships affirms that
relationships are inherent in all
things and phenomena in the world, without
exception.
Regarding the nature of these
relationships, we have three characteristics:
firstly, the objectivity of relationships—the
relationships between things and
phenomena in the world are inherent.
They exist independently, not dependent on
human consciousness; that is, humans
can only perceive and utilize
these relationships, not make decisions.
Secondly, the universality of
relationships—no thing, phenomenon,
or process exists in
absolute isolation from
other things, phenomena, or processes. Simultaneously, the
existence of ideas is an
open system with relationships to other systems,
interacting and transforming each other.
Thirdly, the diversity and richness of
relationships—universal relationships can
be divided into many forms, such as
direct and indirect universal relationships, and
essential and manifest universal relationships.  The
new phenomenon relates to the universal and
secondary connections, the necessary
and accidental connections. The passage about the meaning of the
principle of universal connection states that, as
I understand it, when
considering any object or phenomenon,
we must have a comprehensive perspective, examining the
object or phenomenon in relation
to other objects and phenomena. We must
study its constituent aspects and
its developmental processes. From this, we
gain a correct and multifaceted understanding
of the object or phenomenon and effectively handle
problems in life, avoiding one-sided
metaphysical and fallacious views.
Now, I'll give you a real example to help you
easily understand this principle.
Now, when you want to plant a
tree, you need seeds and soil.
You have to water it every day
and allow it to photosynthesize and be exposed to
sunlight. Only then
will your seeds germinate and
grow, right?
Without these conditions, the seeds would
n't sprout. We can see the relationship
between the seed and the soil.  Similarly, the
surrounding environment has
certain connections with each other. For example, when
we take a math exam,
we have to apply our knowledge of
literature to read and evaluate the questions. Similarly,
when solving physics problems, we have to
use mathematical formulas for
calculations. And when studying
social sciences, we have to apply the
logical thinking methods of natural sciences.
These knowledge areas are
interconnected. Here are
some common connections: for
instance, I'm
growing rice, and my rice field is
damaged. I know that spraying pesticides will fix
it, but if I
only look at the pesticide application
superficially, I'll only see the rice
dying and the harvest bountiful. So
I'll spray as much as possible without
considering the consequences. I won't care about the
connection to the
surrounding phenomena.
Naturally, this will lead to many negative consequences,
such as the death of fish or the growth of
microorganisms.  The benefits of pesticides in the soil, combined with
excess pesticides, will
pollute the soil and water environment. Rice, when
harvested, will be contaminated with pesticides, leading
to health problems for humans.
Therefore, if we don't apply the
principle of universal interconnectedness,
we will have a one-sided view and
handle the problem ineffectively. However, when
we understand and apply
this principle, we will
see that things and phenomena are
interconnected. We will then
know how to adjust and use pesticides
appropriately to minimize the harmful effects,
right?
For example, in
sugarcane fields, there is a pest called the
sugarcane borer. The larvae eat the
sugarcane stalks, causing them to spoil. As
we know, sugarcane with
damaged stalks loses its value. So,
farmers in those areas
raise red-eyed snails, and
when these snails reproduce, they lay their
eggs on the wings of the sugarcane borer larvae, which then
eat the larvae.  This caterpillar
eliminates the reproduction and development of the
sugarcane borer, thereby increasing sugarcane yield.
These farmers
have applied the principle of universal interconnectedness
to their farming practices.
They know that the red-eyed caterpillar and the sugarcane borer
are interconnected;
they don't
love each other. So they let them
live together, and the weaker caterpillar is eliminated, resulting in
healthier sugarcane. Do you
see the principle now? In short, the
principle of universal interconnectedness states that
things and phenomena always exist in
relationships and interact with each
other. No thing or
phenomenon stands alone.
We must view things and phenomena
from multiple perspectives and consider their connections to
effectively address life's problems. That's what
I wanted to share with you
about the principle of universal interconnectedness. If
you found this video helpful, please give it
a like and leave a comment below.  If you're
interested, please subscribe to
the channel and hit the bell icon to receive
notifications about the latest videos. I will be posting
more videos about the
fundamental principles of Marxism-Leninism, and
now, goodbye and see you
in the next video!
[music]